hello everybody this is Peter Cooper
welcome to today's in CBI minute webinar
on the SRA run selector the answer is in
questions that are afternoon the webinar
will be available in a document that
will be a link to their web anarse page
there's also a materials directory on
the FT piece of it as ask these slides
and this compressed URL will take you
there and I'll go ahead and send that
out in the chat pod so I'd like to
introduce Ashley hence who's going to
talk to you today about the SRA run
selector all right thank you very much
okay so here we're going to go ahead and
get started what are we going to talk
about today we're going to talk about
the structure of the SRA database we'll
go through what the run selector
actually is how to effectively use the
filters in run selector getting access
to the data that you found and we'll go
through a couple examples of the SRA
toolkit commands so this is a diagram of
a standard SRA submission setup so up at
the top we have to study submitted and
those are directly linked to the bio
project and they will also have an SRP
accession number in SRA now each one of
these different studies has multiple
samples linked to it and these are
directly linked to the registered bio
samples they will also have a unique SRS
accession now you can see there is one
sample in the middle called control that
is party to both study one and study two
that is perfectly acceptable now
underneath the study and the samples we
have two more categories experiment and
run this information is directly stored
in SRA experiment accessions with the
SRX
number have all of the metadata provided
by the researcher contained within it
and underneath that we have the SR our
numbers which is our run accessions the
run accessions are where the actual data
files for the sequence data are stored
and you can see there are in some of
these samples one experiment linked to
multiple runs and some samples have
multiple experiments and mold
bull runs so there are different ways to
set up SRA to fit your research project
okay what is run selector this is a
table view of SRA data available from
your search terms and we'll go through a
demonstration of this after I've laid
out the basics this allows for more
precise filtering of the SRA metadata it
collates the common columns of data
between the projects with a couple
exceptions there does have to be a ten
percent similarity between the data
columns and fields with large number of
characters will also not be included
because it makes the table harder to
read there is a limit of 20,000 Roenick
sessions that can be viewed in the run
selector and finally after you've
filtered down the data to where you want
it you can export the data accessions
and the metadata as a spreadsheet
alright so let's go ahead and jump into
the demo okay so we're going to start
from the main NCBI page and I have SRA
database selected on the left hand side
and this is where you can enter in any
search term that you're interested in
but be sure your search terms are
relatively specific so you get below
that 20,000 Bron accession limit so I'm
interested in ancient DNA click enter
okay and this will take me to all of the
SRA experiment accessions that we have
for those search terms and over on the
left hand side you can see there's an
access area I want to point out that you
can use the run selector on dbgap data
in this case we are only going to look
at public data however so I'm going to
go ahead and click that and you see
there is a box right at the top that
asks me if I run want to send this data
to the run selector which of course I do
so we'll go ahead and click that and
after it caches all of the data you'll
see a view like this you'll notice on
the left hand side there is a box
labeled as facets this is all of the
data column headers that you can use to
filter the table you'll also notice that
the center is automatically selected
this is just sort of default when you
click on run
selector if you don't really care which
center the data came from you can click
on the little red minus button and it
will make it go away so now I can filter
the data the way I'm interested in and
we're going to start with organism so as
you can see we have lots of different
data for multiple different organisms
I'm specifically interested in human
data so I'm going to go ahead and type
in that genus and when I do there are
two different species for the genus Homo
we have homo sapiens of course and then
Homo heidelbergensis I'm only interested
in Homo sapiens so we'll click on that
one and you'll notice the table
automatically updates I had over 2,000
runs and now I'm down to 486 the next
category I'm interested in looking at is
the assay type so I'll click on that one
and again it also identifies how many
runs are labeled as each of these
categories I'm specifically interested
in whole genome sequencing so we'll
click on that category and again my
table will update make a couple more
selections here I'm going to select a
particular library so we have hybrid
selection unspecified and then random
I'm specifically interested in random
and finally I want a specific spot links
so let's go ahead and type in 60 I want
them at least 60 so once I type that in
you can see there's only three
categories that fit that criteria and I
can select all three of those each time
I do it will update okay so now I have
131 runs that fit the criteria that I'm
interested in
now you notice not all of the accessions
over in the table start with that srr
number or letters I'm sorry that we
talked about these actually begin with
an ER R that means it's coming from our
European database our counterparts in
Europe the SRA database mirrors with
European and Japanese databases for
next generation sequencing data so when
you search our database you're not only
looking at SRA data but you're also
looking at data from those two
organizations so you're getting three
databases and I can also sort each one
of these columns so if I click on it
it's going to sort by the letters and
numbers so forward and then backwards
then I can see all of those SRX sessions
in this case there aren't very many just
simply because ancient DNA is more
prevalent in Europe for doing research
with that's why you're seeing a lot more
grr accessions now you'll notice the
first four columns are blue hyperlinks
and I can click on one of these and it
will send me directly to the information
for that particular run study bioproject
or sample this one looks interesting
just because it says ancient DNA of a
meta genome so let's see what that's all
about I'm going to right click and open
that in a new tab so this takes me to
all of the run data and I can see how
many spots it has the size the GC
content and down at the bottom I can see
the title for this project was
specifically from a tooth for a victim
of the Black Death that's kind of cool
okay let's just scroll out here so I can
show you a couple more things you can
see for some of these categories there
are runs that are blank they the
researchers chose not to enter
information for that particular category
so keep that in mind while you're
filtering these datasets and looking
through them this data is provided to us
from research community so not all of
the columns of data will be filled in in
this case we're doing pretty good there
are some missing collection dates but
let's say all of this data looks good I
want to export it so what I'm going to
do is click the green plus button and it
will select everything in that
spreadsheet but maybe I'm not interested
in that black death victim so I can
unselect that particular run and so you
can see under our selected column here
I'm sorry ro I have 130 runs selected
and I'm going to download that
information and let's save it under
download so I can find it okay now I
want to open that in Excel go to open
this PC will get to downloads eventually
now here I have to make sure I select
all files because when you select to
download the run table information it
will download as a tab delimited text
file so you have to make sure you select
all files and we'll open that now I have
to choose that it is delimited so I'll
click Next and it is a tab delimited
file again next and finish make these
columns a little bit wider okay so now
you can see here's all of that same
information that was in the run selector
is now in my Excel spreadsheet and I can
save it make notes go back to it later
the other option for downloading this
information is just to download a list
of the Roenick sessions this is the most
important accession number that you'll
get from this table because as
previously stated the actual data files
are resting under the run accession
numbers so we'll download our accession
list alright I'm going to open this in
notepad plus plus
okay and here are all my running
sessions all 130 all right let's jump
back into our slideshow here okay so now
you have all of this metadata
information all of these run accessions
how do you get access to the actual data
files you're going to use sra toolkit
this is a command line application that
works on all current 64-bit systems
Windows Mac and we have two versions for
Linux you can download the data in
multiple data formats the most common
being fast queue but for any aligned
data you can also download BAM files and
then we also have SFF files among others
you can also limit the amount of data
that you download maybe you're only
interested in chromosome 1 maybe you're
only interested in the back half of
chromosome 16 you can enter in those
sections when downloading the data and
that way you don't have to obtain the
entire large data file another thing the
SRA toolkit does is blast so you can
blast data from SRA including barcodes
or aligned sequence I'm aligned to
slices I'm sorry
and that's just the beginning ok here's
a couple examples of commands that you
would use in the SRA toolkit to get
access to the data so for a standard
fast queue download you would use fast
you dump and the SRA number this
function also includes options for
splitting files if it's paired data and
also only downloading a section of the
file as previously mentioned if you want
to download a BAM file make sure again
you have to filter by aligned data
specifically you also need to have Sam
tools installed on your computer
because they work together so you're
going to use Sam dump and the SRR number
to get your Sam file and then take it
directly into Sam tools to convert it
into your BAM file and then finally an
example blast command
so it's blast in underscore V DB and in
this case you can see there are three
different run accessions that we're
querying against and the other thing to
point out is this NT test file this is
the actual sequence you
are searching for so here's the
nucleotide sequence to see if it's in
any of these Roenick sessions and then
dot out will give you the results okay
here are the links for all of the
information that we talked about today
including some additional information
about the s alright database and with
that I'm happy to take questions just to
remind you while we're open like this
just if you have any questions about any
of the resources you heard about today
or any NCBI resources in general you can
write to our info address that's info at
NCBI
NLM NIH govt that's the same domain name
as our webpage if you have questions
about the webinar program or webinars in
general technical details about the
webinar please write to the webinars
address webinars at NCBI
NLM NIH govt okay I don't see any
questions that we can answer right now
so thank you very much for attending a
webinar today and that's all for DES
we'll see you next week on the 30th for
webinar about the NCBI hackathons thanks
a lot and thanks for coming thanks
Ashley
you